I just saw a video of a girl talking like that.
Oh I am the daughter of parents with Salvador.
How do you live on this what?
I'm going to do my parents' version so you can have an idea of type what?
It doesn't get in my head.
How do you live that way?
My son in the name of Jesus is treated like a thirteen year old guri.
I am the daughter of liberal parents.
Obviously I learned to drink from my parents when I was.
I think fifteen,
sixteen years old I started drinking my first drinks
and it was my mother who taught me.
Son of liberal parents,
it's obvious that I already did PT with my parents,
it's obvious that I already went to the party with him from getting drunk.
Me,
my father and my mother together were a little controversial
because not everyone agrees,
but that way I am the daughter of liberal parents.
My dad has my search on his cell phone on his iPhone my mom just doesn't
have it because her cell phone on the iPhone because otherwise she would
have it because her cell phone is Samsung her poor thing.
I don't leave this person's vibe.
Daughter of liberal parents.
They give me loving advice.
I reach my dad saying this,
dad I got so cute.
You believe he said that.
That.
What do you think?
Just as I do with my mother,
I am the daughter of liberal parents.
I leave whenever I want.
Unless I need her to need me for something.
My mother and my father father,
it's not like I need you for that.
Here I will stay,
but this is how I do it.
Hey,
I got the car key.
It's in the corner,
go.
I am the daughter of liberal parents.
I hardly lie to my mom and my parents,
and when I lie he knows I'm lying,
he knows I'm doing shit,
you know?
And then I walked by,
I fucked up,
this happened and this?
My mother will look and do.
I didn't know,
since people who live in what world I live in in a fantastic Bobby sauce,
that the relationship with my parents is good.
My mother raised me in the vibe of?
I will not prohibit you,
I will guide you,
because if it prohibits you will be more willing to do and
really you will be more willing to do,
because prohibited is much tastier.
Then my mother really only guided me.
That's it,
a kiss.